madrid est un monstre c'est bien connu
les bruits du trafic les gaz
d'échappement et la chaleur torride pèse
sur la ville une brise maritime
rafraîchissante souffle venant de 400 km
de loin pourquoi aller à madrid quand
d'autres sites d'espagne nous tentent
avec leurs plages de rêve
parce que madrid défie tous les préjugés
la métropole et variés à un paysage
fascinant et est entouré de villes
historiques tels que par exemple tolède
forge de l'âme et ancienne capitale
d'espagne
le château aranjuez les montagnes
enneigées la mannschaft souhaité par le
vent avec les moulins de don quichotte
et la résidence royale el escorial
laisse des indications inoubliable
madrid ville de renommée mondiale dont
le charme réside dans sa contradiction
dans les facettes du paysage urbain doit
être découvertes par soi même le ciel au
dessus de madrid est presque toujours
serein il y à 200 jours de soleil par an
dès été extrêmement chauds et des hivers
très froids détermine le climat
continental sec des hauts plateaux
castillan madrid et la ville d'europe la
plus haute 650 mètres au-dessus de la
mer
plus de trois millions d'habitants
vivent dans la capitale
presque autant de visiteurs qui affluent
tous les ans
il y a beaucoup d'églises ici mais
aucune cathédrale importantes comme à
séville ou à tolède le pays andin est
caractérisée par l'architecturé moderne
contrastant avec les édifices
historiques
14 kilomètres à l'heure et la vitesse
moyenne des voitures plus d'un million
de madrid
souvent des jeunes sont au volant cac 40
5% des madrilènes au moins de 30 ans
vous
la ville s'étend sur plus de 600
kilomètres carrés la zone d'habitation
s'étant continuellement à la périphérie
madrid et le centre de décisions
politiques d'espagne elle est la
capitale de l'administration un centre
d'industrie ville de congrès
d'expositions mais aussi capitale
européenne de la culture 2009 192 madrid
se situe géographiquement au centre de
la péninsule ibérique
elle devint capitale du royaume qui en
son siècle d'or se mua en une puissance
mondiale
le kilomètre zéro depuis lequel toutes
les routes d'espagne sont mesurés se
trouve au centre de la ville à la puerta
del sol le point zéro se situe
exactement devant le bâtiment du
gouvernement régional
du temps des moore se trouvait là la
porte est de la ville derrière laquelle
on voyait le soleil se levait la porte
du soleil disparu la place puerta del
sol de murailles de 20 depuis le 19e
siècle point central de la ville une
scène de la vie citadine à laquelle même
la siesta n'est pas sacré bureaux
magasins et stations attire vers ce
noeud de communication ou 10 rue se
croiser
la plaque tournante de la circulation
puerta del sol est également sous
terraines trois lignes de métro
importante se croisent la construction
de la plus grande station de métro de
madrid influence à l'aménagement de la
partie supérieure de la place plusieurs
entrées furent mises en sous sol ainsi
il fut fait place pour la zone piétonne
autour de la fontaine de la puerta del
sol
naturellement en plein coeur de la ville
se dresse l'animal l'héraldique de
madrid
l'ours grignotant à un fraisier la
puerta del sol était le décor d'
événement politique important
c'est ici qu'est klata le 2 mai 1808 le
soulèvement contre l'occupant français
et en 1931 la deuxième république fut
proclamée philippe iii qui triomphe à
cheval en souverain absolu au dessus de
la place mayor rappelle le xviiie siècle
cette place contrairement à la puerta
del sol dégage une atmosphère paisible
dans la vieille ville
sur la place et sous les arcades invite
des cafés et des magasins de souvenirs
des souvenirs ils sont vendus qui
cultive l'image de la ville par exemple
des petites statues de toreros le
commerce tient une place importante mais
la plaza mayor était vraiment comme on
le voit ici
du temps où il n'y avait pas encore
darren le lieu où se tenait les corridas
peu de gens connaissent encore se passer
la statue équestre de philippe iii est
une relique incontournable des temps
anciens le roi habsbourgeois transféra
ans et 101 la cour de madrid à
valladolid avant que les conseillers
municipaux dollar et attire airs à
l'aide de 250000 du cac peu après il fit
aménager la plaza mayor qui offrait des
coulisses merveilleuse pour les
événements du siècle d'or s'annonçant à
cette époque madrid comptait cent mille
habitants
les gens simples vivaient autour de la
place coiffeur rémouleur artisans et
commerçants
où
les habitants de la vieille ville
appartiennent aujourd'hui encore à la
base couches sociales les plus riches
préfèrent le quartier à la maca à l'est
de la ville durant le siècle d'or
les résidents de ce quartier était moins
bien lotis on vivait ici dans la peur et
la fin mendiants et escroc couraient les
rues on ne ressentait pas cette ambiance
romantique actuel de la vieille ville
seule la co organisait aux alentours des
fêtes somptueuses mais inaccessible
les habsbourgeois s'illustrer en tant
que mécène philippe iv attira à la cour
les plus grands peintres et gens de
lettres diego velazquez francesco des
soldes par anne lopez et vega et
calderon de la barca
ce sont eux qui d'horaires cette époque
au contraire de la multitude de magasins
d'or et d'argent de la vieille ville
ils sont là depuis peu tels les vendeurs
aveugle de billets de loterie que l'on
rencontre dans tout madrid
il
l'histoire de madrid et documenté au
musée aux municipales musées de la ville
le portail baroque richement décoré
mérite une respectueuse attention c'est
une oeuvre de pedro de ribera ce lieu
d'habitation insignifiant jusqu'en
neuvième siècle ne s'appelait à
l'origine pas madrid mais en arabe
marit lieu de nombreuses eaux à l'est du
fleuve manson ares les morts
construisirent vers 860 leur alcazar la
forteresse fut conquise par le roi
castillan alfonsi ce 11ème siècle pour
les chrétiens la ville s'agrandit mais
resta insignifiante seul lorsque l'aps
bourgeois fils et deux filles
en quinze 161 de l'alcazar sa résidence
madrid 20 capitale du royaume ainsi
apparurent églises et monastères dont
les tours surplombant la ville sous les
rois bourbon qui début du xviiie siècle
remplacèrent les apps bourgeois
l'absolutisme français s'impose à
comme aucun autre charles iii marca le
visage de madrid
celui qui fut le premier et meilleur
maire de la ville fit installer des
canalisations et des éclairages publics
les constructions les plus marquante fut
réalisée sous son règne comme par
exemple l'église san francisco del prado
et le palais royal
au début du 19e siècle napoléon expulsé
à la famille royale espagnole
la haine d'une domination étrangère
conduisit à la guerre d'indépendance le
2 mai 18 cents vite jour au cours duquel
les occupants tuèrent de nombreux
madrilène sur la plaza mayor et dans le
parc retiro devint le mobile préféré de
la résistance espagnole
un tableau de goya porte d'ailleurs le
titre dos des maillots ultérieurement
bien qu'en fait ils rendent hommage au
frère de napoléon
le musée de la ville montre aussi
l'histoire de la vie quotidienne de
madrid
ainsi qu'elle se laisse aussi documenté
par de multiples preuves de la vieille
ville l'église san pedro el viejo est
une des nombreuses constructions sacré
au sud de la vieille ville la plus
grande est représentative maison de dieu
exposé san francisco et green day alors
que la cathédrale provisoire san isidro
au contraire de celle de barcelone ou
séville n'est pas importante
ainsi cette église de l'ordre mendiants
san francisco du xviiie siècle fut
aménagé beaucoup plus généreusement
joseph bonaparte voulait transformer la
coupole en un panthéon mais il fut
chassé de la ville auparavant
mais
je suis un autre
autrefois les moutons et les boeufs
était attaché un pieu abattu et traîné à
l'aide d'une corde sur le lieu des
ventes une trace sanglante demeurait en
espagnol as trop c'est ainsi qu'à paru
le nom du célèbre marché aux puces de
madrid
il a lieu tous les dimanches dans ce
quartier de la vieille ville
dans le triangle formé par la ronde à
des toledo la calle des toledo et la
calle d un bar à dos reis on trouve de
tout des poupées des masques des
miroiter bénitier des pistolets de vieux
clous des vestes 9 et des choses folles
et le dimanche passé bien entendu sur
leur astre au don quichotte et sancho
pança en miniature sont les stars on
pouvait les admirer sur la plaza de
españa en grandeur nature les corail as
les dernières ancien cours autour de la
vieille place d'abattage reste cependant
cacher aux yeux des curieux
les brocantes sont dans toute ville des
attractions touristiques tels par
exemple le marché aux puces à paris
contrairement à ce marché aux puces le
plus célèbre d'europe leur as trop de
madrid par et ancestrale malgré la foule
leur astro et l'histoire vivante de la
ville ainsi que le comprennent les
artistes qui paie mire les murs des
maisons alentour
dans le proche voisinage de el rastro se
trouve la place laval pièce elle
rappelle celle présente dans les
villages espagnols typique sans faste et
cents statues de bronze peuple et à leur
place des habitants du quartier l'ava
pièce est bien plus qu'une place l'ava
pièces et la ville du dessous de madrid
des pots de fleurs cachent les murs en
ruines
l'idylle est trompeuse aucune façade est
aussi bien conservé que celle ci
des petits magasins et des bars des
femmes au foyer faisant leurs achats
elles rentrent à travers les rues raid
accidenté souvent étroites et falote
lava pièce n'attire aucune foule de
visiteurs
ce n'est pas un quartier latin
pittoresque hala madrid jusqu'en 1492
après qu'ils furent brutalement expulsé
par le roi espagnol vivaient ici les
juifs lavapiés signifie en hébreu lieu
des juifs et donna vraisemblablement
ainsi son nom au quartier le ghetto juif
n'existe plus mais la vague pièce est
resté populaire sur la plaza del accords
à la dé sa foi là ce sont donnés en été
opéra du petit homme pourrait-on nommer
ces vaudevilles dans lequel était relaté
les problèmes actuels du quartier mais
qui cela intéresse-t-il encore la
télévision livre aujourd'hui des soap
opéra et le monde entier dans chaque bar
il existe une multitude de bars à madrid
la télévision est allumée par tous et
atténue la mélodie de reconnaissance des
distributeurs de billets depuis que le
jeu de hasard interdit sous franco et de
nouveaux permis pas un espagnol ne peut
résister à cette attraction
on joue avec bruit est en train toute la
journée dès le matin on boit du vin ou
de la bière accompagnés de tapas des
petites amuse-gueules variés ils sont
dégustés presque sans pause malgré les
repas principaux habituel bien manger
est un points centraux de la vie des
espagnols c'est pourquoi il n'est pas
étonnant de trouver à madrid un musée du
jambon les pièces exposées peuvent être
dégustées sur place
après qu'on les admire et en détail
accompagnant nourriture et boisson la
musique qui colle dans le sens des
espagnols le flamenco
les rita noces gitans apportèrent le
flamenco en espagne de vieux films
sortis les archives d'une école de
flamenco montre que cette danse n'était
au départ pas une mais un chant rituel
qu'il exprimait les sentiments et les
états d'âme des rita noces la guitare
inspire aux chanteurs de nouvelles
variations de vieux thème
la célèbre danse flamenco apparu
beaucoup plus tard
pendant des siècles les gitans dansait
et chantait seulement entre eux ce qui
maintenant à madrid séville barcelone
les bongo ce jusqu'à san sebastián
appartient à la coutume espagnol fut
l'ont interdite ce n'est que vers la fin
du xviiie siècle que cette forme d'art
fut connue du public
madrid est un des centres les plus
importants du flamenco à côté de hauts
lieux andalou comme séville et cadix
autre tradition la garde royale montée
elle se trouve sur le chemin de la
relève au palacio real le palais royal
dans l'ouest de la vieille ville
leroy habsbourgeois philippe iv auquel
madrid doit son apogée artistique le zig
lodeiro posant fiers cavaliers sur la
plaza de oriente et entre le théâtre et
le palais royal
le palacio real de style baroque tardif
une construction carrée à 4 elle confère
à la puissance dominante absolutiste une
expression architecturale
tout à côté du palais se dresse la
cathédrale la almudena elle est dédiée
au saint protecteur de la ville et
n'impressionne pas outre mesure
entre l'église et le palais de nombreux
touristes se pressent quotidiennement
pour voir l'ancienne centrale de la
puissance du royaume espagnol le plus
représentatif des bâtiments de madrid
construisit giovanni battista sacchetti
l'ordre fut donné par le premier roi
pour bon philippe 5 à qui la vieille
forteresse de l'alcazar ne plaisait pas
lorsqu en 1734 la forteresse souvent
reconstruite brûlé entièrement ont pu
enfin copier le prestige de la cour
française
le palace et au real devait surpasser
son modèle versailles les escalier
majestueux en marbre
créé par francesco sabatini conduit dans
la salle du trône royal
la salle est garnie de tentures murales
des lustres gigantesque illumine le
riche décor les deux trônes ne sont
occupées par le couple royal que lors
des festivités
la peinture allégorique du plafond est
un hommage à la couronne la grandeur de
la monarchie espagnole avec ses
provinces et ses états la fresque de 26
mètres sur onze mètres réalisé à deux
mètres en leur art
le vénitien giovanni battista tiepolo et
son fils domenico la partie
particulièrement impressionnante et le
côté ouest du palais au 2,43 m il est
tourné vers le campo del moro dont le
nom provient des anciens lieux de sièges
des morts de l'autre côté au nord en
direction de la plaza ds pana se
trouvent les jardins abati nez ils
suivent le modèle français des jardins
baroques sévère et géométriques
francesco sabatini et l architecte
préféré de charles iii sous la régence
duquel palais royal fut terminée et les
jardins aménagés
ils sont le rendez vous préférés des
jeunes et des plus vieux surtout par
plus de 40 degrés à l'ombre
la plaza de españa salut par dessus le
parc jusqu'à l'ancien palais royal
le palais dans lequel les monarques
espagnols résidèrent jusqu'en 1931 se
dresse en contraste voyant avec le
visage moderne de madrid
le bail laine brute passant devant le
palais fait partie de ce contraste une
artère principale de la ville
en face du palais la plaza de oriente et
offre une oasis de tranquillité et de
repos comme beaucoup d'autres parcs et
des espaces verts
oh
à côté de la plaza de oriente et se
dresse le monastère des augustines real
monasterio della encarnacion il fut
fondée par les pousses de philippe iii
et abrite aujourd'hui une collection de
reliques ainsi qu'un musée d'art
strictement séparées des pièces dans
lesquelles vivent les religieuses
de l' axe de circulation baelen se
détache plus au sud le cahier mayor
cette liaison entre la résidence royale
et la puerta del sol était autrefois la
rue la plus importante et la plus
élégante dans laquelle noble et
fonctionnaires vivaient seuls les loyers
pour un appartement dans un lieu si
central est bien desservi sont
aujourd'hui royaux dans la calle mayor
se trouve la halle au marché mercado
dessin miguel l'offre séduit habitants
et touristes
la calle mayor fut le lieu de naissance
de l'eau pdv gars le plus célèbre
dramaturge du siècle d'or
il écrivit plus de 1000 pièces de
théâtre ceux qui s'y intéressent
apprennent cela à la mairie au guichet
informations le petit magasin discret
d'en face peut facilement passer
inaperçu cependant pour les guitaristes
le nom senor contreiras est une
référence dans l'ariège pièce réalise un
des plus célèbres fabricants de guitares
ces instruments estimé par tous les
musiciens du monde à la main avec
beaucoup de patience et des années
d'expérience
chaque instrument est une oeuvre d'art
faite de bois précieux
chacun d'eux est signée et numérotée
m
on
où
e
nous
les artistes viennent de très loin pour
choisir un instrument dans cette palette
de guitare précieuse nous revoici dans
le tumulte de cette grande ville qui
malgré le chaos continue elle de la
circulation offre des places de repos à
l'ombre la plaza de españa a l'air plus
petite qu'elle n'est à cause de ces
autour elle est pourtant trois fois plus
grande que la plaza des mayor
l'édifice iodé et span a de l'air franco
est une coulisse pour le monument de
servante il honore le créateur de don
quichotte de la mancha miguel de
cervantes le chevalier à la triste
figure ainsi que sont nés trois sancho
pança mondialement célèbre don quichotte
se précipitaient obstinément dans les
vastes plaines de la mancha sur les
ailes des moulins à vent qu'il prenait
pour des chevaliers l'attaquant le
combat était vain comme le combat de la
république espagnole contre les soldats
révoltés ses partisans de franco opérait
depuis une caserne qui autrefois se
trouvait sur la plaza de españa pendant
la guerre civile suivante les madrilènes
se défendirent plus de deux ans et demi
est accusé à de nombreuses pertes mais
les troupes de franco vainquirent don
quichotte devint un symbole de cette
résistance la place elle le centre de
l'espagne franquiste
après la destruction de la caserne la
place pury aménager les hauts bâtiments
surplomb de la plaza des spa nahd depuis
les années 50
aujourd'hui elle est un lieu de repos et
après la plaza de colomb la plus grande
place de madrid
la torre de madrid haute de 124 m se
laisse conquérir sans peine en une
minute par l'ascenseur au 32e étage
le café invite avec un panorama
grandiose à ses pieds
m
il
mon jeu
non
mais
si la torre de madrid offrait une
certaine vu sur la route de la mer ainsi
s'ouvre une nouvelle perspective entre
les gorges des bâtiments les boulevards
somptueux de madrid
la gran via agit sur les touristes comme
d'anciennes promenade noble alors que
les parisiens flânaient depuis longtemps
déjà sur les champs elysées madrid
n'avait pas encore de rues de luxe
sur la planche à dessin les
planificateurs de la ville avait en 1886
déjà élaboré la tranchée est-ouest
controversé qui devait partager la ville
mais auparavant beaucoup de rues et de
maisons devaient être détruites avant
que la gran via ne fut commencée en 1910
fin des années 30 les transformations à
tenir enfin la plaza de españa les
constructions répondait aux techniques
les plus nouvelles on resta fidèle à ce
principe jusqu'à nos jours
il y a partout sur la gran via des
horloges et des thermomètres numérique
qui laisse paraître nostalgiques les
horloges traditionnelle et richement
décorés
l' architecture liée à la volonté de
représentation sans pare d'éléments de
style baroque et classique
les bâtiments de prestige ont perdu de
leur éclat du temps de leur apparition
cependant la gran via dégage aujourd'hui
encore l'aura d'une grande ville
ce qui contribue totalement son la
circulation incessante les grands
cinémas et les magasins de mode très
cher madrid et la capitale politique et
le centre de la haute couture d'espagne
madrid le soir le temps de la movida
commence le temps pendant lequel tout se
mette en marche
le trafic est toujours aussi énorme tous
se jette dans les plaisirs de la nuit
madrid est illuminé la grande ville
présente une coulisse pompeuse à madrid
les décors du soir sont souvent imprégné
de contraste à côté des rendez-vous
branche est bondé il y à des lieux
calmes et romantique comme la plaza
santa anna dans la vieille ville où on
peut déguster au calme une bière des
tapas ou un vrai repas
la movida est un cortège sans fin d'un
établissement à un autre écrit hans
magnus enzensberger avec pertinence
une visite au théâtre apporte un
changement au rituel de la soirée mais
on préfère mettre son apparition en
scène tant d'efforts nécessite bien
entendu un montant on déguste à chaque
gorgée une des offres appétissante de
tapas
particulièrement pittoresque sont les
barreaux carreaux de faïence avec leurs
assauts l'eros en espagnol carreaux de
faïence
enfin avec grande imagination autour de
la plaza santa anna plusieurs se font la
concurrence aux faveurs et à la
considération des touristes pour les
motifs les plus jolies et les plus
drôles
bon
m
ans
se divertir s'amuser et la devise
accepté à l'unanimité
on reste debout jusqu'à l'épuisement
physique
matt rythmé matin madrid me tue soupire
un de ceux qui furent emportés la nuit
précédente par le tourbillon de la ville
alors il est nécessaire de combattre sa
gueule de bois à l'aide d'un fort café
noir dans l'un des cafés traditionnels
les cafés tertulia tél ls perrault ou le
café gijon ne sont que deux rendez-vous
remarquable dans lesquels tertulias des
discussions sur des thèmes différents
ont lieu
partout dans la ville pas seulement ici
sur le paseo des récollets tos des cafés
attendent les noctambules et ceux qui
font leur première pause travail de la
journée
tout à côté se trouve la plaza de la
cibeles dénommé d'après la fontaine du
même nom charles iii ont souhaité à la
construction un char tiré par deux lions
puissant avec ib les la déesse de la
fertilité et grande mère de tous les
dieux
entouré par le trafic des axes
importants se croisent en ce lieu se
dresse cibeles devant le bâtiment des
postes surcharger 2918 auquel on donna
le sobriquet de cathédrale de la
communication à partir de là ces tirs le
paseo del prado vers le sud sur lequel
les habsbourgeois flâner déjà plus tard
le bourbon charles iii le fit
transformer en une allée embellie avec
des fontaines et des arbres
sur le boulevard de luxe se situe deux
nobles hôtel comme par exemple l'hôtel
palace où tout à côté du prado l'hôtel
ritz
entre le ritz et le musée du prado se
dresse la statue du peintre goya pour
voir son oeuvre et celles des autres
célèbre peintre espagnol 1 million de
visiteurs par an se pressent dans la
plus grande collection de tableaux du
monde
le bâtiment de style classique était
prévue fin du xviiie siècle pour être un
musée de sciences naturelles avant qu en
ils ne reçoivent la collection royale de
tableau devant la façade principale du
bâtiment accessibles et rich man trône
le plus important prince de la peinture
diego velazquez sur la place à des mots
rio au sud du prado se tient le 3e de
l'association du triumvirat tu des
peintres espagnols
bartolomé esteban murillo il est un des
plus importants représentants de l'école
de peinture de séville des 5000 oeuvres
du prado quelques-unes des plus
importantes
jérôme bosch réalisa avec le jardin des
délices une oeuvre principale
énigmatique de la fin du moyen âge
il paie ni le triptyque verquin sont à
l'apogée de sa créativité d'une
imagination débordante
il créa de nombreuses créatures et des
scènes unique
le chevalier à la main sur la poitrine
un des meilleurs portraits du greco
montre un fier caballero
le tableau de goya lte rester maillot
est dramatique
il rappelle l'exécution des insurgés
espagnoles elles cuisent sasol a porta à
goya une certaine considération mais sa
célébrité
ia doit surtout à deux tableaux maya
veste ida et maya desnuda
velasquez benji à l'âge de 30 ans le
triomphe de ben arous avant de terminer
30 ans plus tard le tableau le plus
connu du prado l'asmi menace les ménines
l'infante marguerite marie se trouve au
centre du tableau avec des nains et ses
filles d'honneur on aperçoit derrière le
groupe dans le miroir le couple royal
dont velasquez fait le portrait
à l'est du prado en direction du parc
retiro se trouve le cas sound el buen
retiro
jadis une salle de bal et de réception
elle appartient aujourd'hui au prado et
abri derrière sa façade néoclassique la
peinture espagnole du 19e siècle
après la visite du musée il faut juste
traversé la rue alphonse 12 pour se
retirer
se reposer dans le parc d'en face aussi
simplement s'explique son nom le pack
ray tir haut
ce poumon vert à l'est de la ville
comprend 120 hectares au début du xviiie
siècle
philippe quatre filles aménagé à la
périphérie de madrid
ce vaste parc attenant à la résidence
d'été buen retiro
la course a donné ici à ses plaisirs
quand elle était fatiguée de ces tâches
l'entrée était interdite aux gens du
peuple cela changea quand charles iii le
roi réformateur éclairé ouvriers en 1767
le parc au public
à une condition chaque visiteur devait
être lavés et bien vêti
de nos jours on n'est pas aussi strictes
ceux qui recherchent le repos venant du
quartier chic de salamanca appartiennent
aux meilleurs rupins aujourd'hui tous
peuvent tout de même prendre plaisir aux
clapotement de la fontaine
le lac aménagé est le point central du
parc ça arrive est détournée par la
statue à cheval d'alphonse 12
non
deux bâtiments attire de par leur
architecture le palacio des velasquez
une construction en briques de 1883 orné
de décor en céramique et surtout le
palais de cristal voisin le bâtiment
faire et anvers fut également érigé fin
du 19e siècle
il servait au départ à l'exposition de
fleurs aujourd'hui le palacio de cristal
abrite un musée d'art moderne
le petit lac devant le palais sert
souvent de coulisses lors de concerts
classiques
les fans de jazz et de rock se retrouve
au contraire devant le grand lac la
tradition du parc remonte au couple
royal catholique d'isabelle et de
ferdinand qui déambulait dans les
jardins du monastère saint jérôme ce
site fut détruit par les troupes
napoléoniennes
seule l'église entre le prado et le parc
retiro fut conservée elle est une des
plus vieilles maisons de dieu de madrid
dans laquelle juancarlos fut proclamé
roi en 1975
au sud du paseo del prado se situe le
jardin botanique de nouveau le roi
planificateurs et progressistes charles
iii fit aménager le jardin pour
encourager la recherche dans les
sciences naturelles
aujourd'hui on peut y faire des
découvertes littéraires dans le magasin
originel les amis des livres recherche
des rares it et bibliophile avec de la
chance on y trouve parfois une ancienne
édition du don quichotte de cervantès
le jardin botanique frise la plaza del
emperador carlo 5
elle referme en tant que pendant de la
place cibeles au nord le boulevard du
prado au sud
deux bâtiments domine la place de
gigantesques figures de bronze attire le
regard vers le ministère de
l'agriculture
de l'autre côté la station atocha
impressionne c'est la gare qui date de
1892 dans le hall de 27 mètres de haut
et de 152 mètres de long ne s'arrête
plus aucun train en 1992
le vieille halle fut transformée en un
jardin de pamiers
on atteint la nouvelle gare par des
escaliers roulants les trains à grande
vitesse de la ligne madrid séville
arrive ici
à proximité un hôpital du xviiie siècle
a été transformé en un centre important
pour l'art moderne
le centro de arte reina sofia doit
devenir le bras d'eau du xxème siècle
dans le bâtiment carré à la verte cour
intérieure des oeuvres des artistes
espagnols modernes les plus importants
sont exposés sur plus de quarante mille
mètres carrés tels picasso miro dali est
ta pièce le sophie doux montre aussi des
oeuvres d'artistes contemporains la
dictature de franco méprisait la plupart
des artistes espagnols moderne
c'est pourquoi leurs oeuvres furent
dispersées dans tous les musées du monde
un tableau pu être regagnés et constitue
le point central de l'exposition
guernica 2 pablo picasso ce tollé contre
la guerre a pour thème la destruction
totale de la petite ville basque de
guernica en 1937 l'armée de l'air
allemande soutint franco dans ce
massacre de civils
picasso créés à ce tableau en quelques
semaines pour une exposition parisienne
l'oeuvre reste à des décennies à new
york au museum of modern art selon le
testament de picasso il revint après
l'ère franco à l'espagne
le fait trop d arte reina sofia et le
prado transforme le paseo del prado en
une rue des musées à travers toutes les
époques le boulevard s'étend jusqu'au
nord de madrid
on passe devant le palacio de
villahermosa le musée de la marine
lafontaine cibeles jusqu'au passé au
terreau et colette hausse
certains des 50 musées grâce auquel
madrid est devenue une capitale de la
culture se situe encore sur l'allée
comme par exemple le musée d'archéologie
et la bibliothèque nationale
les deux se trouvent dans le bâtiment
qui fut commencée en 1886 la reine
isabelle 2 posa la première pierre de ce
temple de la science la bibliothèque
comprenant 4 millions de livres servi à
des fins universitaire
un perron imposant conduit au complexe
géante
la collection art géologiques montrent
des antiquités préhistoriques ibérique
est classique
la variété du musée éprouvées par les
oeuvres artistiques et artisanales
allant du moyen-age au 19e siècle
la dame del compte parmi les pièces les
plus importantes
la sculpture de calcaire datant du 5e
siècle avant jésus-christ semble
représenter une déesse des morts le
musée national d'archéologie se trouve
juste à côté de la plaza des colonnes la
plus grande place de la ville quatre
blocs monolithiques rappelle le siècle
d'or du royaume espagnol dans le jardin
de la découverte de l'amérique le plus
grand honneur et un monument sont
naturellement du homard un génois
l'explorateur cristoforo colombo il
était au service de la couronne
espagnole
cristobal colonnes en espagnol columbus
se dresse sur un socle ornementale néo
gothique et regards par dessus la place
et la ville columbus exposé à son idée
trouve et l'inde en empruntant la route
maritime de l'ouest pendant sept ans au
portugal à l'aide de nombreuses lettres
en vain les souverains catholique
espagnole lui donnèrent une chance
ferdinand et isabelle l'art maire de
trois navires nina pinta et santa maria
le 12 octobre 14 192 columbus posa le
pied sur la nouvelle terre qu'ils prient
pour l'inde
ces quatre voyages apportèrent au
royaume castillan gloire et richesse la
découverte de l'amérique et des
indigènes que columbus à plat les
indiens transforma décisivement
l'histoire mondiale
les promesses faites par les souverains
ne furent pas toutes respectées columbus
mourut déçus et amers de la place
columbus par la castellana une autoroute
urbaine qui semblent infinies et qui
partagent madrid en deux du nord au sud
elle est la prolongation direct du paseo
au sud et conduit à la madrid moderne
avec ses gratte ciel
les hauts bâtiments les plus connus sont
hors et picasso torreilles europa et
taulé sol ou b2 monde s'est parlé
construction d'acier de verre et le
vieux madrid
ici les avis divergent comme pour les
corridas il y as soient des partisans
des aficionados soit de durs adversaires
mais ces derniers sont rares madrid
et comme séville le fief des corridas
une de ses stars
le torero ortega cano donne son avis
nous savons que la mort existe dit horta
go canaux mais nous sommes lâche et
voulons nous cacher mais la mort nous
rattrape
le torero lui est plus proche que
d'autres tu enfiles tes vêtements de
toreros tu regarde dans le miroir
tut examine tu te confesse et tu le sais
la mort est là le plus important dans la
peur et la mort et que l'on se bat
contre elle jeudi ne m'approche pas trop
j'avais en finir avec toi c'est ce que
je dis chaque jour quand je quitte la
maison et part pour la corrida en dehors
de l'espagne à part en amérique latine
la corrida est refusé en espagne aussi
les protecteurs des animaux sont pour
son interdiction
que dit le matador canaux devant ses
protestations
en tant qu'espagnol les toreros je crois
que beaucoup sont contre parce qu'ils ne
connaissent pas la raison réelle de ce
spectacle la signification de
l'existence de l'animal la mystique du
torero l'apport artistique que le combat
de taureaux représente je ne peux être
contre tout ça si je ne le sais pas le
taureau de combat est un hymne à noble
il continue à se battre chevaleresque au
mans même quand les picadors l'on punit
de leurs lances
aucun animal ne se bat ainsi alors que
la possibilité de fuir existe le combat
de taureaux est une fête typiquement
espagnol qui plaît aussi dans d'autres
pays
la corrida débutent chaque dimanche sauf
en hiver à 17 heures exactement en plein
été à 18h le combat de taureaux est bien
le seul événement ponctuel en espagne
dans l'arène la plus grande d'espagne
las ventas plus de vingt mille
aficionados tremblent pour leurs héros
des stars comme ortega cano où jadis el
cordobès gagne des milliers de francs
par représentation
le jeu contre la mort attire déjà les
plus jeunes des enfants de 7 ans
apprennent la corrida bien que celle ci
finissent parfois mortellement alors
deux des toreros et la mère de l'animal
vaincu moeurs ainsi le veut la tradition
tradition et modernisme villes mondiales
et villages espagnols capitale
culturelle européenne fief des corridas
du flamenco de la circulation chaotique
et la mer est à 400 km alors pourquoi
madrid parce que cette diversité n'a pas
son pareil